i mostly cook for myself
so i see that it's almost uh uh this is
gonna be like the worst term but like
an act of uh self-love
uh this is gonna be clipped out
that like it's almost an exploration of
like what brings me joy
and it's surprising because i usually
don't share because the things that
bring me joy
are the simplest ingredients like i'm
one of those people
i don't know if you can psychoanalyze me
because you also like basic ingredients
i like a single ingredient two
ingredients because
i feel like i can deeply appreciate the
particular ingredient then
i get easily distracted you know people
who are really good listening to music
they can hear a piece of music
and in their mind extract the different
layers and enjoy
different layers at a time like the bass
the drums
the different layering of the piano the
beats and all that kind of stuff
that's what it means to truly enjoy
music to listen to a piece over and over
like almost like as a scholar in that
same way for food i just can't do more
than like three because then it's just
i have to uh give in to the chaos of it
i guess but when it's just a basic
ingredient
like just meat or just a vegetable like
basic grilled without sauces without any
of that
that i've discovered is what brings me a
lot of joy but that's boring to a lot of
people
so i usually have to be kind of private
about that joy
so but that's mine so i figured that out
and i guess as a as a chef you have to
figure that out
about everybody that you care for well
also
for you you're very interested in things
and
and interested in things being done well
and appreciating them so
the single ingredient also allows you to
control for perfection and cooking that
which is probably really
appealing to you um and i think
sometimes i see people also in the
beginning of their journey of
culinary trying to do too many things
right so there's another piece too
that you'll notice if you recall last
night i grilled us the salad
right and then i did all those pieces
separately and that's something in
general
to be really attentive of when you're
building flavor to make sure you
pay attention to every piece separately
um you know the idea that you can okay
with the soup or something or stew
there's there's workarounds
but like to make a great dish that's got
four or five vegetables in it
cook them all separately to their
optimal deliciousness and then combine
them
so that's another way to approach that
is that you may also be able to look at
the different ingredients separately
and still have that sense of like
understanding of it
but there's too often that we're
layering together like four or five
things and then cooking them all at once
and then surprised that it's not
delicious
yeah because you can't you can't really
optimize on multiple variables at the
same time for
peak awesomeness and that's actually you
know the the number one way you see this
is roasting a whole chicken
which is a really difficult it's the
simplest dish but it's very difficult
because you have the breast meat which
is bigger chunks they cook faster you
have the the thighs and
drums which are um smaller and they cook
slower
to optimize that and pay attention to it
and do it all right they're you're
actually solving for different outcomes
so there's a there's one example but
oftentimes food is less delicious with
multiple ingredients at the start
because we're not able to pay attention
to how each one needs to end up
so there's a way to parse that apart and
achieve a better outcome
you